so last year I'm here and there was a a
couple man and a woman they were they
were just like kissing and hugging all
night and I'm like this is a nice couple
you
know and I say to them I'm talking I say
to them I go so you got kids and they
were like yeah I go how old are your
kids and they tell me and I go that's
cool I go and I asked them another
question about their kids and the guy
goes yeah we got kids but not
together I go oh he goes we're actually
we're married other
people and I said what he goes yeah yeah
we have kids but with other people we're
married to other people now what I
thought was they were both separated and
they had gotten together and that was
their cute way of their entry into we're
separated love each other whatever you
know so I said oh I go you guys are
married to other people I go oh I said
but but like
the other people know you guys are here
together right and the guy goes I
[__] hope
not yo this whole the whole room was
like what the [__] do we do with this
what are we
what people were not sure whether to
laugh or whether to be like what is
happening right now and he thought it
was way funnier than she did uh and so I
said where I go wait I go you're the
other people don't know you're here
together the guy goes no and I go yo
dude I go obviously you live your life
the way you want to live your life but
like it's kind of ballsy talking about
that in front of a room full of people
and he goes like this to me he goes he
looks behind him and he
goes I live an hour from here I don't
know any of these
people there they're sitting right here
yo from the darkness from back there I
just hear somebody scream I know you
mark yo Mark's butthole was
like yeah I was like oh Mark you better
enjoy this night cuz the rest of them
are going to be [__] from here on
out okay this next story happened last
weekend
[__]
[__] [__] walk by me in the stupid
[__] outfit and [__] say some
stupid [__] like that [__] you [__]
you that was my Uber
driver somebody didn't want his cheese
recommendations
apparently
that is for sure not a Wisconsin acent
[__] you [__]
you I do love that though like I'm so
curious how that started because for
someone to be mad and be like you got to
walk by me in that stupid [__]
outfit I want to see that person so
badly I can't even tell you I'm not
going to lie to you I almost walked off
stage and be like I'll be right back
I'll be right back
I'll cuz that kind of cuts to the Bone
cuz after that dude gets in that fight
he's going to look in the mirror like I
thought I looked okay tonight I
don't I bought this shirt today from Jay
crew
I I like it a little weird guys can I
tell you by the way the last time I was
here in Texas maybe the weirdest thing
ever happened at one of my shows for
those of you who follow me you know that
I like weird [__] um I talk about it a
lot and because I talk about it a lot it
shows up at my shows every now and then
I'll do something called um called the
dance off and I'll bring people on I'll
bring people on stage and I have them do
like a interpretive dance behind me and
the winner wins their server $100 right
and so one question I ask all of the
contestants before they come on stage is
what's the name of your best dance move
so this woman a couple weeks ago took
her [__] eyeball
out oh it's on my Instagram feed it's
it's yo so I asked her and go what's the
name of your best dance move and she
goes the
Cyclops oh my God now I I I I at the
time was like well I don't can't even
imagine what that looks like you know
and so I was kind of imagining and so I
started to play the guitar and she did
one dance move this way one dance mooved
this way and then just took her [__]
eye
out did you just take your eye out she
started dancing it with it in front of
me and I was
like okay you don't need to do that I
don't I don't want to see that ever
again is anyone here when that drunk
lady
was [__] crazy was that crazy there
was a two young ladies sitting here and
an older couple man woman sitting here
oh yeah and so she was eating food off
the table and so finally the young lady
goes to her she's not
that and I say to her your mom eating
all your food she goes I don't know
[Laughter]
her this trunk lady was just sat with
other people and with the guy dropped
food she just started eating their
food
there was a dude once who was like I
want to come on stage with you and I was
like I don't I don't understand that
request and he just kept talking I want
to come on stage with you I want to come
on stage with you and I'm like but what
do you have to offer dude like if
everybody is in here you're G to come on
stage and interrupt the show what do you
have to offer everybody and he goes if
you let me come on stage I'll let
somebody in the audience come on stage
and kick me in the nuts I'm like come on
up
now I have this happened a couple years
ago but it's posted on my Instagram and
so I asked the audience this was in
Philadelphia I figured I'd get a couple
of people who'd be like [__] y' I'll
kick that dude in the nuts right now and
so he he gets on stage and I I here were
the rules he had to face the crowd and
she was going to kick him up underneath
well I want you guys to get the read on
the face you know what I mean this isn't
funny but that's funny you know what I
mean and so I asked the crowd I'm like
who wants to come kick this dude in the
nuts and this one woman clearly had
probably just got out of a terrible
relationship and she was like I will
kick him in the nuts right now and I was
like and the guy said to me he got
nervous he was like anybody
else I'm like no this is who's coming up
so we made I made her invent a wrestling
name because if you're going to kick
somebody in the nuts on stage you get
out so she her wrestling name was
Thunderclap she came back the next year
with Thunderclap t-shirts and handed
them out it was [__] great but so
this dude Heckle so I made him sit like
this and
she
guys she goes I don't want to kick him I
go listen this is Philadelphia one of
you is going to get booed it's either
you for not kicking him or him for not
going down and she was like I'm GNA kick
him I go get in
there guys she [__] wound up she
started doing this by behind him to
stretch and I turn to the guy go you are
in
trouble she's doing this she's like let
me stretch it out I'm like yeah do what
you need to do girl she goes like this
and just [__] she gave it like um
anyone ever played baseball you familiar
with the Crow Hop you know the Crow Hop
is like the to get into it she gave
herself a little and then
just lifted him like this and made the
[__] movie
noise like that I was like oh that
really
happens [__] dropped him was amazing
I I've tried to replicate it nobody else
will let me yeah go ahead yeah yeah yeah
still watching porn my parents still
watching porn kick this guy out of
[Applause]
here you know what bothers me about you
ask asking that is that you are not that
much younger than my parents so I'm
assuming that maybe they're watching
porn cuz I'm sure as [__] know you are
that you're right
yeah all
right cool thanks for letting everybody
know you're going to go home and jerk
off later that's everybody needed that
mental image everybody
needed
wife's not here I'm ready to go right
[Applause]
now [__] yeah all right I like that kind
of aggressive masturbation energy I like
that and a small penis during sex being
a nurse trying to fight a small
penis not not sure why you wanted to
share that
uh so are you you're a nurse what she
said was you think a small pen penis
during sex is bad try being a nurse
trying to find a small penis all right
are you saying he's
naked he he and he's there's nothing
covering his junk and you still can't
see it no it's gone it's like in the
balls it's
gone no longer
there so it retracts like a
turtle
yeah yeah and is is that just like cuz
it's nervous like I'm
shy or it's cold or what is the reason
that it sinks in it lives like that it
lives like that don't say it like
that sounds like a horror movie it lives
like
that
what does it come out ever to be like
peekaboo like like is there any of
that diing for they go digging for
[Music]
dick and don't keep me a suspense till
they find it or how does this story end
I want to
know D oh wait did you hear what she
said you got to grab a couple of
buddies wait okay okay okay hold on wait
wait okay okay hold
on so it's inside like an inie belly
button and it stays in there and and and
is he in the hospital because it's in
there or it's just it's just a [__]
happy accident okay and so when this
person gets aroused does it I have no
idea you're going to leave me hanging on
that
what if his hard on goes out his [__]
because it's a [__] it's like a revers
SE and it just goes you're like oh
[__] when he lies he's like Pinocchio
and his dick comes out of his ass like
what the
[__] wow and so is that how you met
him
[Music]
it wow I want to tell you something for
real I know at first I was wondering why
she wanted to say that but I am so glad
you
did thank you for sharing with the class
I really appreciate that I didn't know
that was a thing but I'm going to
[__] Google the [__] out of it when I
got any dicks I don't even are you also
a nurse I was long you medic for a long
time the budding system she's talking
about is like two hand
placement hold on hold on you're going
to need a microphone for
this everybody she's going to tell you
about the buddy system for
your just in case anybody in here has
got an innie she's going to help you out
hold on here we go this is what we do
you've got to make the triangle with
your hands and put pressure around the
basis of where the turtle's hanging out
in his Co
hold on hold on hold on I just saw you
know in this analogy the turtle is the
dick or the balls the dick the dick so
the tucked away dick okay can we make an
analogy so the turtle's swimming around
in this little pool
like and he's like I want to come up for
air but he he's underwater he can't come
up yeah the hands are the food and
they're put on the side so maybe he'll
come out and show his face sometimes you
got it's like Groundhog
Day is it winter when the dick comes out
is that what
happens now can I ask you
something okay okay okay can I ask you
is this your boyfriend your husband okay
it's all right dude so Ken and I know
this is weird but I don't have a good
visual will you just get can you show me
the triangle on his dick so I see what
the [__] you're talking
about I know you don't any D she
wouldn't have she but I just can you
yeah just can you can you just give me a
little so I can see what's
[Music]
happening I think we're all curious I
think we're all
curious you don't have to if you don't
want to dude just do it on that dude
instead she's like no that's cool I'm
good all
right wow
okay by the way anybody else have
anything they want to
share oh I can't wait to tell that story
wow
yes your husband had that
problem by the way so did
[Laughter]
you wait is that him right there oh okay
yo you see him he's like
no
I got a big dick big [__] dick I got
a big
dick I'm sorry I'm sorry no no start
over start
over it does come out it does come out
okay out of his
[__] oh on the front part yeah m is
it is it
okay I just want you to know how my
brain works I have like 180 more
questions and I'm not going to ask you
any of them I'm just going to Google
them but thank you thank you [__]
thank
you and I don't even know what prank he
was coming over to play on me cuz he was
supposed to what kind of was
she
[Applause]
let me let me handle that
question I would actually like to let
you handle it out first of all I've
never heard so many vowels in the
room you used all of them multiple times
with no consonant which was really
impressive it was like you
couldn't like you you just couldn't stop
him from coming
[Applause]
out that was amazing um I think the
answer
is
no I'm not sure it seems the safest one
for that question I think yeah would you
like
to would you like to
would you like to rephrase that question
with actual words next
[Music]
time should should I still answer the
first question I don't [__] remember
what the first question was I do I
remember what the first still trying to
play Scrabble back there I don't know
how much that word was worth but all of
it
probably yeah it seems like you hit
every letter except for Z and X so
that's the total number on
that you win Boggle too I
guess
anymore it'll keep coming out yeah but
I'll
stop what was the question she said we
were just laughing because his
grandfather was in the hospital that
needed to use duct tape to control his
nuts you know you you you could have
just put some underwear on the dude you
know what I
mean he didn't have to tape his ner his
like that seems extreme you could have
just tried clothing I don't
know explain to me what happened so tell
me what
happened he a trucker he was a trucker
like what he asked
for oh he asked for jump tape on his
nose please I
du he wrote a note to the nurse please
can I have duct tape I keep sitting on
my
[Music]
[Applause]
balls you you know I got hit Christmas
is a Crown Royal bag
[Applause]
and just stum them in there s that [__]
up you going to be fine
D first of all never going to that
[Laughter]
hospital they were like Dr good idea
yeah we got something El we keep them in
the nut drawer that's perfect
okay wow by the way your grandfather's
hard as
[__] get me some duct tape for my
nuts that's the greatest Generation
right there I just can't figure out how
they would wrap the duct tape
like do you think they made like
underwear do you think they made like a
duct tape like a
cup I'll figure it out at home I'll
f i I have to tell you a couple things
my my real question isn't who who who
throws a dildo at somebody my real
question is who brings one to the
[Applause]
show you know what I'm saying like I
guess if you got it and you're looking
for them the SL that makes sense to me
but who's like oh I forgot my deal you
know what I mean
like I really got to check what kind of
advertising I'm putting
[Applause]
out
cuz if she was like I can't forget my
tiny little dildo tonight I got to make
sure to bring
that I'm not going to lie to you the the
balls
uh for real they look like my dog nuts
before we got them
[Applause]
cut yo I wish it was one of those things
that just never stopped doing this
[Applause]
magic two balls tell me if it's true
uh yo for real it looks like an Olympic
High Dive board
[Applause]
just
but
[Applause]
[Music]
like just the way it's shaped it looks
like a real Curious dick
[Applause]
like like it's looking for answers
like oh dude this could be the whole
show I'm telling you right now I could
do this all [__] night are you
kidding me God damn oh my God all right
yeah all
right